so let's get this ball rolling
what are your highlights from season
three for both if you were in it your
character and more generally obviously
everyone's going to say the red wedding
so i thought i'd get in there first
um
yeah i i enjoyed season three from
hodor's point of view i got to do a
little bit more freaking out and stuff
you know um
yeah it's just a different different
note for the character but but he didn't
love the red wedding i mean it was just
it was terrible and it was it was
it was wonderful at the same time i mean
so that was definitely my highlight
yeah thanks man
so the red wedding was really amazing no
i mean it was uh incredibly pulled off
and i i mean i know a lot of the guys in
the show obviously and
i've stayed away from i you know i tell
them not to tell me what's going to
happen because uh
you know i'm a fan now you know i watch
it and i didn't know that una chaplin's
character was
was gonna go in the way that she did
which is particularly brutal um they
really don't they they don't pull their
punches they yeah they don't hold back
um
so yeah i really yeah i mean that was an
incredible way to incredible moment in
the series what was it like having
played renly seeing loras what he was
getting at two last season yeah
yeah it's difficult to talk about
i mean actually
genuinely when when they were filming
that finn liked to send me pictures of
him and the actor who played his lover
on a boat in the in robes uh nat dormer
loved to text me foes and then hanging
out together i was like this isn't funny
and i'm just texting back that you know
me and jason mama were doing well in the
afterlife and you know having a great
time um no yeah it really no it's it's
incredible to see what they're doing the
character now fantastic thanksgiving and
how about for you ian what is what are
your highlights in season three
uh well all right i've gotta say
something other than the red wedding
um i guess my highlight was uh
and this is actually more from sort of
like being in it rather than watching it
was um
whenever daenerys
has kind of won over the city of yunkai
and and they come out this is the end of
the series they come out and they sort
of like you know
lift her up and those dragons are flying
overhead just to hold the whole magic of
that moment and
the admiration for her i guess you know
that was a great moment for me and
that's why i remember shooting in this
fabulous sort of
uh casbah um
outside because we filmed in morocco
exclusively that year for that part of
the story and uh
there's this amazing chasm that we
filmed in not far from what is out of
where the studios were so that was a
special moment for me
how about you luke
um i'm supposed to leave like from a
personal perspective um
spending this much time in for my
character i spend something crosses
keeping about four thousand women and
fall out eight and then actually
and then working with uh obviously james
cosmo like i think
don't hear that
um
he's amazing that guy is actually a part
of christian the biggest man in the
world i think fighting james cosbo
is the best thing i've ever done
what are you jim
yeah
season three i only got to um do one
scene which was um yeah lucky enough to
be in season three watching it was
obviously the red wedding um i didn't
see it until uh the first thing about
the red wedding i saw the youtube videos
of the reactions first and i was like
i'll go and watch this sunday
something's happening or now so yeah i
couldn't wait to watch it season four
for me obviously i had much more um
involvement
um and i was yeah back at castle black
so um
yeah
yeah
good stuff thanks guys now i want to ask
you touched on season four there how you
all found shooting uh season four
compared to previous seasons and for you
guessing i wanted to ask what your
favorite memories were shooting those
seasons one and two i have lots and lots
of fond memories uh i really it was
really interesting to watch the jousting
sequence in season one to remember that
i'm remembering being very very hot
but we were there for like six days and
it was a really fascinating lessen in
how
television is made you know it was a a
complicated sequence and seeing things i
mean like highlights
for me uh
just as an actor was really learning
from you know guys like ian and and
you know mark and and conless and people
i've looked up to from a little by way
you know and that for me was a real
privilege
and there were lots of ranks like that
you know um and then i guess and then in
season two what they did with the story
and introducing
um natalie dora's character marjorie and
and how intense they made those little
relationships was really great for us
all i think we enjoyed playing those
scenes and getting the most out of those
relationships so yeah i mean i mean
there's like every day was a highlight
you know so
i can imagine definitely how about for
you ian how do you compare choosing
season four
i mean uh
likewise i mean that joystick stuff it
was amazing
and to actually see it put together and
how they put it together and the amount
of care and attention that's put into it
and that's one of the things about this
series they they're it's very
painstaking a lot of care intention is
given to
realizing those scenes a lot of the big
scenes they need a lot of work and
they're amazing the way they do them but
i love that horse the horse that lost
its head that was amazing you know it
was amazing amazing uh piece of
construction and amazingly clever the
way they did it i mean some of the
some of the set and prop building in
this show takes your breath away i mean
the sets we have in the studios in
belfast
some of them are phenomenal you know
phenomenal there's there's new ones will
be coming up live seriously you won't
have seen
and they're so lifelike
and then you go in and you energy you
look at it it's just a bunch of
polystyrene or whatever it is or a bit
of wood painted
marble but it is actually
extraordinary what they do
so you kind of
one of the things about this is i think
you know you go in as an actor we you
know we're a bit like the baxter rugby
we get all the accolades you know and
the rugby the the forwards and rugby
have to do all the grunt work you know
and this is you know this sort of thing
is much the same there are so many
people who do so many incredibly
detailed
crafts craftsmen like jobs in this then
you have to you have to applaud them you
know and as i say i'm just overwhelmed
sometimes but just the quality of the
detail and the imagination
because in the armor and costumes and
set all that kind of thing and of course
the cgi boys are amazing as well the
highlights
for myself um
for the characteristic um
pip gets to work with some other
characters i can't say what i can't say
who
but yeah
get to work with um different characters
um
it's showing me how unfit i am
so i gotta get fit again for season five
um
yeah it was just amazing to be um back
at castle black um
i've never gone anywhere except
castlevania
so it's like at home so um yeah i love
it um yes season four was just was just
amazing um
the stuff i saw um
yeah people are going to go crazy for it
when it comes out
yeah that's what i can say how about you
the difference between like season four
and threes like my storyline it's
not a massive world departure still in
the same sort of place as we have been
for the rest of it but i suppose what
expect season four from like my
storylines
i get to be more than just sort of like
miserable in this season which is a
massive step up for me
and i kept the station
don't understand the scale
of this stuff and the detail in it is
phenomenal i mean if you look at castle
black and like
those places actually exist they're not
just
like backdrops or they they're actually
there
in middle of nowhere actually these
little huts and castles just fully
scaled and probably could operate if
they wanted to before it's it's it's
unbelievable it's not just impressive
because they're so big it's impressive
because the amount of care and attention
paid to the whole thing and
for me it's just it was like it was my
first job and i was like is this what
every job's like then
i was like ah no it's not i don't know
how about you christmas well how does it
compare making season four to the
previous season um i think compared to
season one to three and we have done a
lot of camping
um
really in season three we moved from
campsite to campsite killed a few
rabbits
um
but i think you got a sense of at the
end you've all seen season three
yeah
well
i don't care i mean really but
we kind of go under the ball and we're
going into the wilderness and basically
you've got a handicapped kid
you've got two other kids and you've got
me who's not much use
really and you get a sense that we're
gonna end this impending danger we're
probably not gonna make it but really
that's what season four is to me it's
like we've been right into the unknown
and that we're really vulnerable
and
yeah we definitely get to play on that
season for it's it's it's a lot
different there's no camping
no marshmallows um
and yeah from season wasn't stuck out
for me i had to do that bloody nude
scene um
anyone else here how to do a new tune
yeah
yeah
a sammy
i'm still finding bits of pubic hair
stuck to me
um
it was richard martin he came running up
to me in the car park and he had
strapped on to
make your prosthetic christian and okay
but also they actually made the funny
thing is they actually made two of them
um there was one with like type afro
hair which obviously i've got gray hair
guys
which obviously wasn't mine and there
was one more like me so
if you want to tell the story it's
really awful
definitely tell that story
i'll do it really quickly because you
guys have heard of it fifteen thousand
times
right basically they said it was a close
set
um there wasn't there was like 300
people there they made these really
horrible prosthetic penis panties
and
horrible had to be cgi knights they had
to plot the pubic hair into my own pubic
hair
awful per makeup girl
and i had to paint it to my own skin
color while it was on me
um yeah so we had to do the same it was
in a forest glade and carried off
outside belfast
and and it was raining the power
generators kept going out
and um there were two fellow children
here
okay
there were two pheasants who wanted to
love each other
on each side of the of the set and every
time i came out in this prosthetic penis
pants um the pheasants were to call to
each other and go
so we had to we had to keep re-doing the
same
it was definitely one of the worst days
of my life
and they talk about the glamour of
acting
now guys let's open up the floor who's
got questions for any of our cast
members here today taking one in the
front row festival yes this guy here
which character deaths uh surprise you
like the most
obviously the big one right
that's wrong yeah i enjoy the books so i
was like when i read that
i was uh how how they kept captured the
uh death of roz asmodko's character
i was sort of struck by just how
beautiful that shot was i mean it's an
incredibly
difficult image to look at for lots of
reasons obviously but it and so to
capture their very static almost almost
respectful way i don't know i don't know
what i mean by that but i that image has
sort of you know like
really told that story very simply
a very very difficult story to tell and
i thought they did that well you know
yeah gosh
that joffrey absolutely yes
anyone else want to say what the most
surprising death was on the show apart
from red wedding
um it's hard to get surprised my mother
is a huge game of thrones fan and long
before i ever had the part and basically
when i got the part she said okay he'd
actually 1992
even when i got the scripts it wasn't
really much of a surprise
yeah it was totally ruined
the great thing about
the deaths
is that you don't see them coming
you know that's the great thing they're
so shocking because there's no way which
is sort of like prefigured so i mean
obviously the death of ned stark was
sort of astonishing i came across that
first reading the book
and he is so much the hero and sort of
the moral kind of center of the piece
that you expect you're going to go
through the whole story with this guy
and he's going to be your man and there
he goes you think where the hell do we
go from here you know
i have a great sympathy for the stark
family because there seems to be an
agenda get rid of as many that was
possible
but i have a sneaking feeling that there
will be
some
this is not something i know this is
just me positive gas here
that it's somewhere another the stocks
are going to
come back on top in some way i don't
know what yet but some stark is going to
emerge uh you know
triumphant in some way i hope i think
yeah the return of the starks we all
wait with basic branch who do you think
deserves to win the iphone
definitely not a lannister and it's
about time some one of them some several
of them got their just desserts
um
it's kind of changed over the last few
seasons actually i obviously want stark
on the throne um
i don't think they wanted by the end of
it but i think probably arya um
oh yeah we're brown
i think brown will also be a fantastic
king um although i feel like he's got
bigger issues on his mind
yeah i think are you oh he's a good
choice she's a badass
how about you get this yeah we saw okay
i think we've talked about this before
we came up with this idea of like a
small council
or you know running running the show
which has like arya and bran and brienne
there and
maybe
yeah
you know
part of like you know
a strong group of you know good people
you all touched on briefly with some of
the sets that you've seen but what are
your personal favorites of some of the
sets that you've actually been on in
game of thrones the first set i got to
shoot on was the small council
that was my day one
pretty much everybody was there and the
reason why i remember that so clearly it
was my first onset but also
it it was like walking into a caravaggio
painting like the way it was lit you
could see the shafts of light
i mean it really was like walking into a
painting and i think that is something
i'll never forget
um
also renly's camp on the beach where i
had an army and that that was pretty fun
yeah awesome
did you feel like you could take over
the world that day well actually funnily
enough i do remember a very distinct
feeling of having a crown on my head
seeing my sort of the army the
supporting artists walk down to the
beach on day one of filming at regulars
camp and i sort of had this little
thought in my head like i guess it's a
hubris you know like
oh yeah it would be pretty good to be
ken yeah
and the universe conspired to uh send a
small hurricane through the set and we
had to cancel filming for about a month
um
that set was amazing because i got we
got to do it twice it was a set so good
we built it twice um but yeah
anyway any other takers for that
question there's a
i think i could say this without you
know getting my fingers cut off there's
um
some brilliant pyramid sets coming up in
series four which are stunning and the
same thing it's not just the sets look
great but they're brilliantly lit
and the same thing you get these
wonderful shafts of light coming through
they're gonna they're gonna take your
you know your eye out because they
really are incredibly impressive my
first day shooting it was in heavens in
winterfell um
and it was the arrival of the lannisters
um to winterfell with with um mark ali
and everything i think i think this is
the biggest get-together of cast ever
and people who will never meet again
and at winterfell
first in season one it was inside a real
castle in northern ireland but um
during the filming they broke part of
the castle so um they had to move it for
season two and i remember thinking
myself how could we create this
so we went to like in the middle of a
field and this time
just in the middle of nowhere and they
lifted the castle and completely moves
it edge per inch but literally every
grain of
straw you don't have grains of straw
okay pieces of straw every piece of
straw was exactly the same but it
smelled the same it just felt like a
real castle
it's incredible the level of detail like
everyone says we're all going to say
this it's the sets are just unbelievably
real my very first day like well even
like on this show whatever my very first
job i remember we did at castle black i
went walking in and i was like oh it's
gonna be like in the studio you know
somebody go in and there's actually a
castle there and like four hundred
dollars a crew and peter dinklage and
james cosby looking and owen deals
and i was like that is
unbelievable it wasn't actually just a
set that shocked me i think what people
don't always talk about somehow is the
locations i mean we spent about a month
out in iceland
and that was
in its own way
even beyond
that it was incredible i mean the
location scout is amazing in this really
i mean
for me like i was like this is a job
this is unbelievable i mean i just
hung around in iceland for a bit and
then knocked about the castle
such a privilege to be a part of this
project no matter how big or small you
know and then can i just start by
congratulating kristen um thank you for
being so brave
coming out just a couple of days ago so
i'd like to thank you for giving hope
and inspiration to young children who
are still in the closet i just like to
say thank you
hair and stuff like that makes it worth
it you know but i have to say you know
i've been out since i was 14 years old
the first person i ever told was my
mother you know it's just i've been
lucky to have the support of my friends
and family my entire life
but
it was just so weird to mention
something so casually in an interview
and because it's not a big deal to me i
i expect it not to be a big deal to the
rest of the world you know and it
shouldn't be a big deal to the rest of
the world for anybody
but
what i've said is if one person out
there can feel a little bit better or um
identify with one other person it's you
know i'll take the flock i don't care
like i have my support network
and i don't care what people think about
me as long as your friends and family
are there so
but there you go
and can i just ask if your character
could meet any other character in any
situation who would it be in one alexia
yeah i'd like to meet her when she's
older in season three balon greyjoy
received his son's penis in a box
what's the worst present you've ever
received
actually this time i received a penis in
a box
i gave um young jack gleason a present
once and he sent it back
because on the set i'd write him little
notes from uncle renly telling him to
stop being a naughty boy and i said it
and i sent him a jelly baby
as a gift into his trainer with a little
note telling him what he should be doing
and you know
and he sent it back with the head bitten
off
at least he didn't try to re-gift it
with the head of it
yeah it's really random it's just
literally nothing to do with game of
thrones it's the worst present ever when
i was like five years old um literally i
remember this is how scarred i was um
my grandfather said i've got the best
present ever and i thought that's kind
of like a hayman figure or something and
it was four pots of yogurt
it was a five year old there were four
pots of yogurt
without a [ __ ] presents
um
my presence has been all right it's just
from um i used to work at a um a double
glazing company while i was trying to do
the action like um working myself up and
um
i kind of hit the targets and um they
said we've got something for you and it
was just like a
alarm clock from the pound shop
that was for hitting my targets
i was always early so i don't know why
i've got an alarm clock
right yeah that was that was the most
crappiest present i've ever got
plus how to buy a battery
if it was up to you to finish the books
what would you do with the character of
joffrey
you know he's got to die you know
i mean one of the things that's kind of
surprised me is that how much people
hate joffrey and don't seem to have the
same
antipathy to cersei
i think she's got to go as well i mean
i've never been a fan of cersei either
is there something you can do that's
worse than killing
yeah what's that
i don't know what it is
we
any other thoughts on what you'd like
have done to drop through
you give a like a brand treatment you
push them out of the window and then you
can get the fee on treatment
two together and leave them in a castle
um i don't know if you guys are aware
there's obviously a lot of parodies of
game of thrones there's kind of how to
say this in front of children uh and
adults only parody which i believe is
called game of bones
have any of you guys seen it and were
you disappointed not to appear in it
i haven't seen any of it no i'm very
glad not to
i've seen the trailer but i haven't
actually
gave him a bone
there's a trailer there was a little
trailer wasn't there and then you can
watch the thing but
question for getting you see more
friendly in the show than you do in the
books but there's still relatively
little if you'd have if there was more
sort of screen time what would you do
sort of reading between the lighting
you'd imagined or you know otherwise
what would you add in sorts of things
was that like what what story would you
like to see well um i sort of
as preparation for the second series i
wrote myself a little short story about
what loris and renly did between the
seasons
which involved negotiating military
strategy with mace tyrell
and meeting marjorie and how that went
and the marriage and
and i guess if if i think actually as a
characters them going to meet uh
larissa's father and negotiating a
marriage and margaery
you know once i started thinking about
it actually that's quite an interesting
story so if they were like a spin-off
renly or norris show
dear david
um
i i yeah i think that chapter of his
life would be quite interesting i also
wouldn't like it would be interested to
see him as a younger like
versus a child growing up in that court
when
when robert was a real war hero and like
looking up to his older brothers and why
he was so different from them and i know
i suppose that could be interesting as
well but i mean
every character and the reason why it's
such good drama is every character you
could write a whole spin-off show just
about each character because they're
fully fleshed out you know my question
is for christian because you asked me to
save it to the panel
can you talk me through your audition
process for hodor
you were supposed to forget
um okay i auditioned for a movie called
hot fuzz um which i'm sure you all know
um
rory got the part which i was going for
funny enough anyway um four years later
i got a call from dana gold saying um i
would like you to try out for this part
um for game of thrones so i got 15
minutes to notice i think i had a
chicken
in my mouth i was in a restaurant having
my lunch and my agent called me and
agent he called me um
so we need to find a child
i was like what
we need to find a child for you to carry
and i had to go to this 40th birthday
party um where there was a child
and there was a ring of 40 year old
women
around me
and i was carrying this random child i
didn't know
um and they were all calling me in
different directions and i was trying to
demonstrate different emotions
and then i had to lift the table
above my head
to prove i was
strong enough to do it for the job so
it's extremely random but a couple of
the parts so
you know
you have to do these things i went
through the standard process when i got
a phone call from the agent to go and um
audition but i actually i went through
three rounds going for another part
before i did this
i went for um
grand i did three three rounds of the
ground and then they
just gave me this one but yeah it's
pretty standard i think but it was good
for you joe yeah yeah it was quite um
it was quite a quick process in it with
the night swatch it was just like um we
didn't really keep on getting recalls
and like um you're doing other jobs and
stuff
myself uh
had had an audition um they didn't give
you the script or anything uh they just
gave you your line so i had two lines
and didn't really know what they meant
because obviously i needed a bit of
backstory and stuff like that um
obviously um
they told me
what the line meant and stuff like that
and then um just done it once or twice
and then um
heard like two two weeks later i got the
partners picked
um you know so many people that they
there that day i didn't know
what they were looking for and
stuff like that but yeah just happy
about the part
yeah
very similar i mean i went in and met
them
and
they actually read me for three
different things
um and then in fact i went back a second
time and we were focused on barristan
and uh
i guess about a couple weeks later i got
the word that that was going to happen
so very happy until the party going for
more months and timing already yeah i
read for those three now
how do you get them
very similarly uh went along to a couple
of meetings or a few meetings actually
uh
over over the process um i i just
remember that in the last meeting i
think they made me do the same um scene
where renly speaks to ned stark about 17
times and there was this little
kitchenette at the back of the studio a
little like space where each time they
go yeah and again and i'd go and like
just hide and i'll just be on my own
pretending to be doing some kind of prep
just kind of going
what am i like
what else can i do and then you ready
yeah i'm ready yeah i just just needed
to focus um but yes it was i mean it was
a fun meeting but it was it was like it
was a lot of times it's like am i either
either getting this right or getting it
really wrong but it worked out very well
it's funny because the guy who the guy
who i read with
was
a brilliant actor you know robert
roberts
i'll actually there's no point
robert stan who read in with pretty much
everyone who get who got cast ended up
playing the king steward
in
king's landing because he was such an
incredible actor he read about he must
have read all the other parts four other
people opposite other actors and he was
brilliant every time and the producers
noticed this
demanded that he'd be in the show
himself because he's just incredible
what's the funniest thing that's ever
happened to you on set for each of you a
season one when john john snowman
cat yeah jon snow and sam got stuck in
the lift and we was having lunch we went
downstairs under the tent and then
everyone's like said uh the lift stopped
and it kind of like dropped sideways
and we was all like look at them
um yeah but that was that was quite that
was quite um
funny but obviously we was really you
know
worried about him
no he was it wasn't funny necessarily
for me but someone got a kick out of it
because i was fully dressed up in my
lovely leather outfit for season one and
it was raining outside and the costume
department very kindly gave me an
umbrella and said you know be careful i
was like yeah of course i'll just skip
from my trailer to the studio so it's
about five minute walk so i'm walking
over it's you know really it's um
raining cats and dogs are real fast but
i'm keeping it all protected and then
this big car
a jag just um
swoops around the corner and nails me
completely nails me with a puddle like
splashes all over me and i just stood
there going what i stood there joking
and the driver really lovely big big lad
gets i guess i'm getting i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry and sean bean gets out the
back goes that will funny that
any other funny set stories that's funny
it's his story but um
during during the filming for this
season if there's ever a blooper reel um
this should make it into um
without giving away any of the story i
sort of stand up and warn of danger by
saying hodor and it was on top of this
little hill
and i stood up and i stood up a cloak
and i literally went
down the hill
i was lying at the bottom of this ditch
there's a lot of characters that people
hate
for various reasons but is there anyone
that you think is misunderstood
i think
you know this is going to be
controversial but i think i'm cersei
lannister
slightly because you know i loved i know
this bit wasn't in the book but one of
one of my favorite scenes from from from
anything so far was the conversation she
had with um
robert um about how it all went wrong he
how he never loved her and stuff and you
got to see a bit behind behind the mask
of cersei and why she's so angry and
vindictive and i kind of relate to that
and yeah you know i think there's more
that starts in the midst eye so i kind
of like her
and she's very protective of the
children obviously as well which is
admirable i don't know if if varys is
misunderstood
but i really hope
that there's a good heart underneath all
of that spidering
i don't know i sort of i'm intrigued by
his characters i think but then i i
don't know
little finger
you know i mean the interesting thing is
as you get into this story so many of
them have a backstory i mean if you knew
littlefinger's backstory if you knew
cersei's backstory
tyrion's jamie's
there's an argument that somewhere in
there there's probably a good person
that somebody screwed up somewhere back
there about when you know
but
on the surface it's hard to see that
so guys i've been told that that's our
final question today we've had loads of
time in the cast and we're really
appreciative of being here today with us
and telling us all about their
experiences on the previous seasons and
the one to come let's say thank you very
very
thank you much coming
you